Okay Michael whats the answer? Let's start with resigner resigner.
>> Alright, resigner resigner. Resign resigner diner.
Alright, E, so resigner vs resigner. So resinger,
if A is a resigner that means whenever A gets a red card A resigns. Yes.
>> And that would be a negative 20.
>> Yep.
>> But that's not going to be the answer is it. Because A
doesn't always, A doesn't always get a red card A
sometimes gets a black card if A gets a black
card [CROSSTALK] than a resigner, resigner that means B is
going to resign and, and a plus 10 will happen.
>> Mm-hm.
>> So those are the two possibilities and they're equally likely, so it's a
minus 10 divided by 2 which is minus 5. Right. You were correct, sir.
>> Whew. Alright.
>> Which one do you want to do next?
>> Resigner seer.
>> Okay.
>> So again, oh, so the, yeah, good. This is a good choice, because
now it's the same as argument as before, except for when we end up in
that far right node, and that means minus 20 in half the cases, plus 30
in half the cases Which is a plus 10 divided by 2, or plus 5.
>> That's exactly right. Well done Michael.
>> Thanks.
>> Okay which one next?
>> So holder resigner. So holder reigner.
That means when A, gets a card. A is going to hold the card.
>> Mm-hm.
>> And that's true, red or black.
>> Yep.
>> And then, then, it's going to be B's turn, and B is
going to, oh, we're doing holder resigner. So, it's going to resign.
>> Mm-hm.
>> So, oh, well, interestingly, I think that takes us
to those two leaves, both of which are plus ten.
>> Yep.
>> Because, why does that make sense?
Because B, oh, 'cause B doesn't get any,
no. Right, right, right, because it's independent of the
card. You actually said that when you explained the rules.
>> Mm-hm.
>> So its, its average of plus 10 and plus 10, which ought to be plus 10.
>> It is in fact plus 10. Well done. Okay what about holder's here?
>> Whew, alright, so that's a case where A holds so we go down those
branches and we end up, we always end up in one of the blue circled states.
>> Yep. And
B sees half the time that leads to minus 40, half the time that leads
to plus 30. So that's minus 10 divided by 2, which is minus 5 again?
>> Yeah, that's exactly right. So that's
correct, Michael. And that's pretty cool, isn't it?
>> Yeah, I really like this game. I didn't think you could
have anything that had sort of poker essence and be this tiny.
>> So yeah, so we live in this really nice
little structure here. So I have a question for you.
You ready for the question?
>> I'm trying to guess what it is, but sure.
>> Okay, here's my question. What is the value of this game?
>> I was thinking that you might ask that. So,
can I, can I step through it, is that okay?
>> Yeah, sure, go ahead. So a's choosing the first row or
the second row. So if a chooses the first row, and then
b chooses the column, then if it's the first row, then b
is going to choose the first column. So a's going to get minus 5.
>> Mm-hm.
>> The same story's going to go through on the bottom row. If a chooses
the bottom row, then b's going to choose
the seer position which gets the minus 5.
>> Right. So from this so, it seems that the value of the
games minus 5. But now let's do the same thing on the b column.
So if V, resigns, now a gets to choose resign or holder. And
it gets a plus 10. And if B is a sire. Then A chooses
between re signer and holder and gets plus 5.
>> Yes.
>> So then from this perspective, the value
of the game is plus 5. So, so here's
a case where it better not be that
we could take a perfect information game and put
it into a matrix and get this out,
because this is something that can't, like, it doesn't,
it doesn't fit your theorem, right? We can't get
the value of it by doing minimax or maximin.
>> Exactly, the problem here is that once
you move the hidden information. Minimax is not
necessarily, and in this case, definitely is
not equal to maximin. So von Neumann.
>> Fails.
>> As we all see.
>> Idiot.
>> Yeah, what has, what has he ever
done for us, anyway? His theorems and his computer
architecture that rules the world. Anyway, so we
seem to have a problem here. And the problem
is that once we go to this hidden
information, as I promise complexity enters in Michael, and
now we can't do something very simple with
the matrix, find a pure strategy that's going to work.
It really is the case that A strategy depends upon what B will do and
B strategy depends upon what A will do.
And if you don't already know what that's
going to be, you don't actually have a value for the game. And in some sense
you can get every single one of these
values. So, there's got to be some [INAUDIBLE].
>> I feel like, that's sort of what you'd
expect in a game like this. Right. So, if, because
of the way that it is. If you know that
I'm always a resigner. That I'm always going to, what?
[LAUGH] Oh, that when ever I have a
red card, I'm going to resign, then. You know
that if I don't resign, I have a black card, so you know that you should resign.
>> Mm-hm.
>> Yeah, so it's, it's, it's one of these things where if I
am really consistent and never bluff, say, then you can take advantage of
me, and vice versa. Like, if you always respond the same way to
when I act a certain way, then I can manipulate that. So it's kind
of like this game of this sort of mind game like I want you to
not know that I know the thing that you don't know that I don't know.
>> Right but the problem is that I know what you
know and I know that you know what I know. And that
I know that you know that I know that you know
that I know that you know that you know what I know.
>> Did you really think that I didn't know that?
>> [LAUGH] And so you end up in this terrible situation. But. There
was a key word that you used there, Michael, and it was consistent.
And everything we've talked about so far, pure strategies, is
exactly the same thing as talking about consistency. So, the way
we're going to get around this is, we're going to stop
being consistent, or at least, consistent in the same way. Okay?
>> Yeah.
>> And to cheat here, is that we are now going
to introduce, instead of pure strategies. Let's see the opposite of pure.
>> Is?
>> Impure.
>> Mixed, that's exactly right.
>> Contaminated.
>> No, so, rather than sticking with pure
strategies, we're going to start using mixed strategies.